(audience applauding)
Hey Drew.
How are you?
Doing well. Doing well.
I'm so excited to celebrate this and you, and you know,
you say that you either sink or swim in life
and that you've recently had a revelation about this.
Um, will you talk to me about that?
Yes. So when, when quarantine happened in 2020.
I was hyper-productive and I was doing a lot.
And I remember talking to my late therapist
and she was like, what's going on?
And I said, you know
in times of crisis, people, either sink or swim.
And she looked at me and said
why do you have to sink or swim?
What if you just float?
And it blew my mind.
It was such a revelation, such perspective
because I don't even know what it meant to float.
To float means you're kind of surrendering
and letting things come in trusting.
And I was like, Whoa,
I didn't even know floating was an option.
Perspective shifting.
Well, Luvvie, you're a great person
to ask about this because you're such a doer
and you're so prolific and you never stop.
I mean, your Ted talk has 5 million views alone.
I mean, you are just out there, you have interviewed Oprah.
She has like ordained you, you know.
You started the show the Mic Campaign
17 billion impressions with Glennon Doyle
and Stacy Bennett Eisner.
Um, how do you float
and still feel like your getting it all done?
Is that possible?
You know, maybe you're not supposed to get it all done.
You know, floating might look like surrendering,
surrendering the fact that your to-do list
does not get completed.
It might mean you sleep a little bit more
because that's what your spirit needs.
So floating might actually look like, you know what?
Maybe you are too productive.
Maybe you should relax for a bit.
Maybe you should take that nap.
Wow. It's true
because we're all beating the crap out of ourselves.
We're not giving ourselves grapes.
There is no room for a lack of getting it done.
And you know, I
I'm going to really take that in Luvvie
and I trust you so implicitly.
Yeah.
You call yourself a professional troublemaker
and you're rebranding trouble.
Luvvie tell me everything.
(audience laughing)
So I think being a professional troublemaker
is a good thing.
Because to be a troublemaker is to be a disruptor for good.
You know, the troublemakers in our lives
are the people who speak up in the meeting and say,
Hey let's think about a different idea for this campaign.
They're the ones who ask your uncle to not give that racist
or prejudice joke at the dinner table.
And I think to make troubles a good thing.
I think about the late great John Lewis, who said
we need to be ready to make necessary good trouble.
And that's what being a troublemaker is about.
I mean, do you have any advice for me?
One tip to being a professional troublemaker myself.
I mean, I'm a bit of a ramble.
It's like I'm a real wallflower or anything Luvvie
but I literally want it.
I always want to take life advice from you Luvvie.
Oh man.
That's great compliment.
So to be a troublemaker
you're gonna have to do the things that are scary to you.
So think about it as when you are afraid,
you are being asked to pick courage
because you cannot have courage without fear.
So choose courage.
It's a decision.
Okay. I am so glad I asked you
because fear can be so debilitating.
It really can.
And to say that you have an empowered choice
it's okay to feel that fear recognize it, identify it,
but choose courage.
Yes, absolutely.
Now I want everyone to understand
that don't attach guilt and shame to being afraid.
We're all afraid.
That is a very normal emotion.
That's been human.
But now you're being asked to move forward.
Like you're not being fearless because you're afraid.
You're not afraid.
You're being fearless
because you choose not to do less because of your fear.
And that's what making trouble really is about.
Yeah. I agree.
Sometimes fearless gets like a bad rap
as if you're supposed to just like throw cushion
to the wind and not,
I don't think that's what being fearless is about at all.
No, And Drew,
you are one of my favorite troublemakers
Uh
and that is a badge of honor
You are constant and your whole life has been
about making trouble and about showing up
and about doing the hard things and being real to yourself.
And I think you have to understand
and I hope you're giving yourself that credit
that you have made great trouble in this world.
So I'm inspired.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, Oh my God.
I probably feel like you did when Oprah
like grabbed your head and you were like
I've been ordained it's Oprah.
I feel like that now.
That means so much to me.
And I'm so excited for your new book,
'Professional Troublemaker, The Fear Fighter Manual'.
It's available everywhere books are sold.
Luvvie, thank you so much.
(upbeat music)